in Antarctica everyday is an Olympic one
these emperor penguins are near the end
of a two-week fishing marathon bringing
food for their hungry chicks leading
miles away but a challenger threatens
the entire competition a leopard seal
waves at the shoreline it's hungry too
some Emperor's make the leap onto shore
before it can reach them the leopard
seal is patient it knows it controls the
playing field superb athletes they sense
the leopard seal and reverse direction
in a split second seeing an opening more
and more penguins stream up and out onto
the ice the momentum seems to turn the
way of the Penguins dozens make the leap
to the safety of land until the leopard
seal changes the rules of the game the
Penguins scrambled to get away out of
the water
goat the seal and the Penguins lose
their speed and agility only desperation
remains the leopard seal snares a
penguin with a seal victory seems
certain
but the game is not over yet penguins
will go limp rather than struggle if the
leopard seal loses its grip if any one
of them make a break for it this one is
gone like a shot it rejoins its
teammates safely waiting at a distance
leopard seal though doesn't give up
it still has good field position and now
element of surprise the leopard seal
won't lose its grip this time takes its
prize into the scene for all that won
these competitors have won the fight to
see another day